foreign
this week on forward
we need to deliver a vision where people
actually feel like they have a sense of
purpose and optimism making a difference
because right now people think that you
do something nothing makes a difference
yeah voting harder is not going to get
our way out of this mess people you know
what I mean like that they segmented us
so that our votes are already pretty
much baked into the cake like I feel
like
like dn's here the RNC this is exactly
the situation I would want it's just
it's red versus blue it's easy and and
my mom is still recovering from my
decision I don't think she ever ever
will but we we hope you know you could
say to her you know what I'm in like
pre-med for the country we're gonna get
some freaking CPR on this the station
[Music]
yeah
it is my distinct pleasure to Welcome to
the podcast the co-founder and CEO of an
awesome organization that brings young
people together from across the
ideological Spectrum does that sound
familiar the co-bounder and CEO of
bridge USA Manu Mio joins us welcome
Manu hey Andrew thanks so much for
having me and I gotta say we knocked out
a couple Birds welcome to the hopeful
majority
yes I am a member of the hopeful
majority the people that are like what
the heck is going on so for the people
who don't know what is Bridge USA it's
an awesome org I've attended uh events
and even a national Summit
um either physically or virtually but
what is Bridge USA yeah essentially the
organization was built to solve one
simple need and that is to allow and
give young people the chance to have
conversations with people that are
different than themselves very profound
very easy simple stuff I mean
essentially the organization has college
and high school chapters across the
country and we're building a movement to
elevate the next generation of young
people that feel like politics is not
only too crazy but it's losing touch
with our reality and what we got to do
is we gotta start having those difficult
conversations and critically the the
fact of our work is I mean you think
about this all the time is it we have to
be able to disagree better we have to
live in a society in which we can
actually solve our problems and I see
young people all the time talking and
engaging and our job is to elevate those
voices and and the only other thing I
would say is that to anybody that
listens um and we talk about this a lot
in our podcast as well like you know
it's everyday people that get up and
make a difference you know it does I
mean you got involved in the
presidential campaign out of nowhere you
know for me I was a pre-med student that
had zero interest in democracy until
Milo yiannopoulos showed up to UC
Berkeley's campus and then every
everything went crazy yeah and you've
been doing this work already for a
number of years how many school chapters
does Bridge USA have yeah so we
currently have 55 College chapters 56 as
of today morning and uh 20 High School
chapters
um and we've launched this high school
program because I thought was like you
know it's not just that college students
are polarizing I mean we need to start
creating these spaces as soon as
possible because we're having a hard
time controlling the flow of information
for anybody and so if someone wants to
start a chapter in their high school or
college is that a thing can they do that
oh not only can they not only can they
do that but you literally go to
bridgeusa.org start a chapter High
School College any person if you're
listening to this right now it doesn't
matter where you stand in the political
Spectrum but if you believe that we need
to be United around a mindset a vision a
temperament for how we engage how we
listen to each other again this is not
about what you think this is about how
we think if you feel like we need to
live in a society where we can have
conversations not just get along for the
sake get along but actually have hard
discrements itself our problems Bridge
USA chapters right for you and I think
anybody that's on our side that is
interested in a new way of thinking
about politics the forward party is
something that they should look into as
well oh well well thank you for saying
so Manu you were obligated to do so no
I'm kidding yeah I think I'm big I'm
being held hostage help
um so you've been working on bridge USA
full time uh as the co-founder and CEO
four years uh your parents are probably
like whatever happened to that med
school thing
um what has your experience been like
what are the the ups and the Downs three
things and and my mom is still
recovering from my decision um I don't
think she ever ever will but we we hope
you know you could say to her you know
what I'm in like pre-med for the country
we're gonna get some freaking CPR on
this the station I mean wait we
oftentimes say Andrew and you talk about
this a lot but we're essentially if
you're a liberal we're inoculating
people against conspiracy theories and
if you're a conservative we're
inoculating people against losing a
sense of purpose and self that's
essentially what we're doing I mean
there's three things that I've observed
over the past couple of years and I'm
curious what you think about this
um but here's what I've broadly seen and
you know this world in this country way
better than I do I mean you've traveled
through almost every corner I've mainly
been to campuses and high schools and
we're talking talking about vocational
schools community colleges we're talking
about large State schools all across the
board private schools Etc
the first thing we hear when we're
talking to anybody is people are just
scared people are walking on eggshells
nobody actually wants to have a
conversation I mean how do you have a
democracy if you can't talk to each
other it's that simple so first we've
got to create a safety valve for
people's pressure we've got to create
spaces where people can actually feel
not just safe but feel like they can
productively engage the second thing is
that most people in this country as as
you've seen and you talk about have very
similar aspirations people want a job
they want to live with each other they
want to they want to live in a world
where their kids do better than
themselves they want to live in a
society in which we feel heard
it's not that complicated and and
actually as a young person I graduate
college in 2020 I'm um four three years
out I would say I think three and a half
we'll see
um
and to me I have to ask you like how do
we get here because as a young person to
me this seems crazy it seems like the
moment that we've arrived at is one was
just so profoundly confounding because
the average person like you and I wants
to live in this world that's pretty
similar and yet we see extreme tribalism
polarization yeah um did your parents
immigrate to this country imanu yeah
they immigrated in 98.
um so recently wow my parents immigrated
in the 60s I was born in the 70s and I
do remember a more generally
uh functional form of politics uh and
media there was a uniformity to it that
now people can regard as uh not very
representative
um but there there was also this
zone of consensus uh around uh facts and
decorum and a way of doing things
um now that that stuff's all breaking
down and it's breaking down in ways big
and small uh good and bad I would argue
generally bad
um so the the major problem is that
these institutions are faltering and
they're not able to rejuvenate
themselves and we're not sure what the
new ones are so there are people who are
starting new institutions but that's a
very very difficult process and a lot of
the most important zones of American
life you do have new ones that popped up
let's call it social media networks that
uh mushroomed with Incredible adoption
and whatnot though I would argue most of
those things have been kind of bad for
other institutions
so if if I had to draw it out for people
I jokingly say Democrats and Republicans
were like vanilla versus French vanilla
in the 70s and 80s like which do you
prefer
um and back then they were ideologically
quite similar uh now they started to
diverge
um in the
60s with the Civil Rights Act when the
when the South flipped from Democrat to
Republican uh and then you had a whole
series of structural changes in the 80s
the Reagan Administration got rid of the
fairness Doctrine which meant that you
didn't have to tell both sides of a
particular issue before that you did and
and so if you look at old timey TV
programs you have two people talking to
each other of different points of view
uh and because of that um then you could
have polarized National media uh Fox and
MSNBC were started in the 90s after the
fairness Doctrine was repealed uh then
you had Facebook come online in 2004 uh
and simultaneously the two major parties
became more urban versus rural educated
versus non-educated Coastal versus
interior so instead of having two
relatively identical-ish parties that
had slightly different approaches to to
various issues now they get separated
into genuine uh tribal camps uh and then
the media is egging us on
um to for The Blue Team or the red team
and then social media supporting
gasoline on the whole thing and when you
talk about people coming together and
having discussions matter the first
thing that popped into my mind was the
medium
where social media is not great for
having nuanced conversations it's about
uh essentially trying to stick it to
someone or pile on in a particular way
and then if you show that you're an
effective tribal expresser then the team
goes oh I like this tribal expresser
but they pile it behind you
um which is by the way the way a lot of
cable news and uh works too nowadays uh
so that's why things seem so crazy where
you look up and if you log on you're
like wow this this seems nuts and then
if you even turn on cable TV a lot of
time you're like this he's nuts this
seems nuts I mean heck there was no
cable news uh but before the mid 90s or
so really so this is a one and a half
generation phenomenon I mean this is
what's interesting about this is that
you talk about
um cable news adding us on you talk
about the medium and the importance in
the media the question I have to ask you
is it seems like
um and I mean your case in point uh for
the opposite of this but it seems like
most leaders most media pundits they
when you see them in person they're very
different than what they are on dude
I've been answering like dozens of times
they're they're different as soon as the
camera light goes on why is that you're
like having a normal combo it's like and
it's
well I mean what's odd about this is and
I mean I can attest this like our the
reason why our chapter students really
appreciate having you on campus the
reason why I really appreciate our
conversations I mean the first thing
first time I ever met you and this was
after having met a lot of political
leaders I said was like you're the same
way in a zoom conversation as you are on
TV as you are you know running a
presidential race or you know running
your current uh institution the forward
party but and you've shown that you can
succeed with it it's like why is it is
it profit is it what what drives people
to essentially turn into crazy you know
Robot Monsters when the when the light
turns on now I'm going to quote Jen
palka uh who said something that I I
thought was so spot on I just want to
make sure I get the verbiage right
um so I just want the to to share give
her quote which I thought was
completely accurate when systems or
organizations don't work the way you
think they should it is generally not
because the people in them are stupid or
evil it is because they are operating
according to structures and incentives
that aren't obvious from the outside
so if you look at a cable news Pond and
you're like whoa this person seems a
little bit sensationalist or whatnot uh
they're responding to minute by minute
ratings
literally if people click off during a
segment producers will be on in their
ear almost at that moment saying hey
like switch to Graphics or do something
I mean they have earpieces in
um and there's a lot of financial
pressure there's a lot of jobs pressure
in a Wobegon era you could come on you
could deliver the news just like the
person at the next Channel and you know
the only three channels so you know
there wasn't much Choice
um I mean three network channels I'm not
even like three like you know cable
um man that must have been the age of
the dinosaurs cable mouthpiece you know
it's like Tom Brokaw Peter Jennings and
uh
you know Dan Rather
um and they were frankly kind of
indistinguishable
oh there's Connie Chung in the mix I
love you Connie uh you know so but that
there was a whole lot of uh stately
decorum uh and journalism took itself
very seriously in a particular way uh
but now they're in freaking death
matches for ratings on a nightly basis
and they're seeing their entire space
get decimated they're seeing their
colleagues canned uh and so it's either
play ball or get consigned to Oblivion
is what happens
and so on good days I feel bad for the
people uh who are stuck in this system
Manu uh I'm I'm so grateful the people
who've supported me over the last number
of years because I felt relatively
insulated from these kinds of pressures
um but when I was on TV there were
proddings where it's like hey we could
kind of use
um some energy on on this side uh and
you know if I didn't provide that energy
then maybe I wasn't as back which again
now I'm just like well I don't really
care if I come on your show again
thank you
I am so pumped that the last election is
coming out September 12th the political
thriller by yours truly and Stephen
Marsh the author of the next civil war
will be in stores everywhere but you can
buy your copy right now at
andrewyang.com order now and be the
first on the Block to know how the next
election turns out it has all the twists
and turns will it be the last election
let's hope not Andrew yang.com for the
last election buy it today thank you
love you all
[Music]
the question that I I'm leading towards
I'm thinking about is what do you think
you were able to do that allowed you to
insulate yourself because I mean Jen's
quote speaks perfectly to this like
General I think theory of power that a
lot of people have about Washington DC
and politics institutions which is that
it's not that great it's not that
necessarily there's bad people in places
that the operating system of the
institution institutions is what's
corrupting people almost right it seems
like that's what you're getting at well
I mean they're spending 30 to 60 percent
of their time darling for dollars uh
right and uh that'll mess you up pretty
quick uh I've I've done some Dialing for
Dollars in my life and doing it more
than half of your professional hours
would be insanely soul-crushing and
corruptive
do you think that when it comes to those
institutions and these people and these
processes like essentially the way that
I'm thinking about this is almost if the
United States is a computer uh the
problem is not the computer it's the
operating system that the computer is
operating on and right on and and and go
figure trying to sell operating systems
change oh that's what we're doing it's
good times in the US of a I mean you
know I mean right now I'm running around
saying ranked Choice voting all the time
uh because I'm convinced that ranked
Choice voting is the closest thing we
have to a key that will unlock any of
the other good things what what is
ranked chess voting just for people that
might not know that here are stuff rank
Choice voting is a more modern voting
system that allows everyone's vote to
matter uh and you can cast your vote for
whomever you want and if your person
doesn't win then the your second choice
vote gets counted until someone reaches
a majority of the support so let's say
it was me Manu and three other people
running for office and then we all got
you know 20 percent then in our current
system whoever whichever one of us got
21 would win
um that's kind of dumb
um but in ranked Choice voting they
would take the weakest candidate look at
their second choice votes and then
transfer their votes to the second
choice and continue this process until
one of us had 50.1 percent so that way
whoever wins genuinely had majority
support it also discourages negative
campaigning because in my new trash is
me we both look kind of bad and then the
third candidate benefits it's been
demonstrated to help women and minority
candidates uh so ranked Choice voting it
also by the way gets rid of the entire
spoiler effect because one of the things
that everyone's freaked out about right
now is oh my gosh if
Joe manchin or RFK or Cornell West runs
for president it's going to help Trump
win uh and if you had ranked Choice
voting no problem you could just rank
Cornell West one and Joe Biden too and
rest easy
so it it allows you to break out of the
the binary of the presidential system
why isn't it working why isn't it out
there
oh it works everywhere it's been
implemented uh in New York 85 percent of
people uh want to do it again and found
it easy to use one of the jokes I tell
Manu is that even my seven-year-old can
rank favorite ice creams one two three
like you know it's not very complicated
um so everywhere it's been installed
it's been enormously helpful including
in Alaska where it helped get Sarah
Palin out and marry paltola in and Lisa
murkowski back in even though she voted
to impeach Trump because instead of
having to go through just a Republican
primary which she would have certainly
lost she got to appeal to the entire
general public and then over 50 said you
know what I actually am cool with Lisa
murkowski even though she voted to
impeach president Trump
can I can I run a theory of of my theory
of the case by you
please okay so I've prepped for this
moment for my entire life by the way in
case the listeners are wondering so so
please grade me harshly on this one but
essentially when you think about the
people that um voted for Mary plotoa for
example right or the people that
supported your campaign or the fact that
there's so much cross ideological
composition between Barney supporters
and Trump supporters it it seems like
there is a broad swath of politics where
the the division is no longer
necessarily left right like Democrat
Republican in the traditional sense but
it it might be something more around
mindset Behavior around being you know
anti-establishers as establishment or
being
um more open-minded versus being
close-minded being more Curious versus
being a prisoner of your ideology
do you find that do you feel like
there's a there's a there's a tectonic
shift in in our divisor do you think
that it's still the traditional sort of
diagnosis the challenge how do you think
about it oh I totally agree with you
that uh and I've sat with the rural
farmer in Iowa uh and the black mom in
Harlem and they're concerned about a lot
of the same things uh the the problem
right now is that they're getting
separated into blue zones and red zones
and then we're meant to say like oh you
know who's to blame the person over
there that you disagree with like that
that's why you're mad and Americans are
looking up saying well shoot I guess if
that's what you're offering me as an
explanation meanwhile both of them are
mad about the Health Care system or the
education system or the fight their kids
aren't going to have the same kind of
future that they want and so in in many
ways and this is what the forward party
is doing and Bridge USA as well in its
own uh realm is is that we want to try
and expose this Left Right ideological
Spectrum as nonsense and and
say you know what guys you're being set
up uh you know maybe
our mindsets are a little bit different
to your point or our cultures and
backgrounds are a little different but
you're not my enemy like the enemy is a
system that's
turning us against each other and
manipulating us and not giving any of us
what we want I was at Monticello three
or four days ago which is Thomas
Jefferson's home and I was like man what
would he say you know I found a box of
his hair
his hair did you take it and if this
were as a sci-fi movie you would then
clone him and then he'd pop up and then
he'd bring us all together and then in
this day and age everyone would throw
rocks and I'm being like we hate you
Thomas Jefferson go back to the Grave
where you came from oh man it's a
reasonable summary
it is it is that's that's basically our
politics as Thomas Jefferson rises from
the dead and then everybody just shits
on him do you do you do you think uh uh
I was thinking about this have you
followed vivec the Vex candidacy at all
I think man yeah for sure I did an
interview about him uh with the Atlantic
uh last week did you see the the Iowa
State Fair and and yeah him rapping Lose
Yourself sure
did you have to also milk did you also
have to Milk The Cow the cows when you
were did you have to go to the Iowa
State Fair I went to the Iowa State Fair
twice man because I declared in 2018 and
so then I went 2018 which was not
exactly a positively reinforcing
experience that everyone was like who
the are you and I was like I'm
Andrew Young I'm running for president
and everyone was like whatever I will
say it was a nice change of pace in 2019
because 2019 there were TV cameras and
crowds and people knew who I was there
was actually a video somewhere it makes
me mad that this isn't out there of the
same woman serving uh I think it was uh
corn to me in 2018 and 2019 and 2018 she
was like good luck with that and then
2019 she was like hello and like all
Friday it was like you know the same
person just a year apart because uh you
know I'd been introduced to Iowans in
that time but yeah I'm a regular at the
Iowa State Fair
foreign
think about the term private citizen
keyword private that's what you want to
be when you go online but unfortunately
not a whole lot we do is kept to
ourselves nowadays it's more like
exposed Who Wants To Be An exposed
citizen not you not me to keep my data
private when I go online I turn to
expressvpn because it's incredibly easy
to use to secure my data and it can do
the same for you it will reroute your
connection and mask your IP address so
basically everyone cannot see what
you're doing and you too can do what you
like in the privacy of your own internet
so if like me you believe that your data
is your business secure yourself with
the number one rated VPN on the market
go to expressvpn.com Yang don't forget
to use my link so you can get three
extra months free that's exp r e s s
vpn.com Yang expressvpn.com Yang to
learn more
[Music]
I mean you you basically your candidacy
came out of nowhere I mean most people
in my generation are really really have
a positive view of of your personality
or Persona I mean they might disagree on
ideology here and there but they they
appreciate your Vibe and your
authenticity which is pretty cool I am
I'm so glad that it was one of the most
invigorating aspects of the campaign uh
is meeting young people who'd say to me
by the way they I get this almost every
day they say thank you for interesting
me in politics because before you I
didn't think it was something I should
pay attention to it but because of you
now I I'm actually kind of into it and
I'm sadder as a result no I'm kidding
no well well here's where I I'm not
informed but sadder more concerned and
if you're concerned start a bridge USA
chapter and join the Ford party we'll
we'll try and uh dig our way out of this
mess there you go we're gonna have to
we're gonna have to clip that you should
start a bridge USA chapter you should
think about the forward party and
importantly
we all got to get our head we all gotta
get our heads out of the sand okay
here's here's here's another here's
another sort of thing that I've been
thinking about which is look I mean you
were when I last saw you in San
Francisco you were speaking to a crowd
um in a local uh bookstore in San
Francisco a real establishment here and
I mean the crowd you were rattling up
the crowd about systems change about
processes about the fact that we have to
think not about the issue right now but
our democracy as a whole something yeah
voting harder is not going to get our
way out of this mess people you know
what I mean like that they segmented us
so that our votes are already pretty
much baked into the cake yeah yeah yeah
well the only legitimate course of
action that might make a difference is
if millions of Americans decided to move
to swing States
if you're not talking about that then
everything else is like essentially just
barking at the wind so I I think that
that fundamentally assumes again our
starting point which is that most
Americans are on the same page that and
maybe not ideologically but they are on
the same page in terms of wanting to
live the life they do but how do you
respond to sort of The Devil's Advocate
the critique of that that assumption
which is that in fact there are deep
systemic divisions that require real
Combat oh they're deep systemic
divisions uh is just the question is
right now is this the way to resolve
them you know like I mean it's like am I
gonna just eke out this one thing can
like stick it to you for two or four
years and you're gonna Stick it to me
into four or four years while the
divisions get deeper and more inflamed
that's the course we're on and uh anyone
who thinks that's a path to Salvation I
mean you know I I don't see it really
um so the the question is how can we
change that Dynamic so that there's a
resolution and I would use women's
reproductive rights as a great example
where look right now the majority of
people are not getting what we want in
large part because of the system and
this includes people with ours next to
their name and so if you just decide
look it's team team uh you know blue
versus red then we wind up with this
deranged result that the vast majority
of us don't want
um you should be able to look up and say
you know what
we should try and reorient the system
and then if you get that then you can
put a lot of things in for women's
Reproductive Rights uh you know
reasonable Common Sense firearm
regulation uh uh climate change you name
it I mean right now we're just being set
up uh and it's disintegrating around us
all the time I I remember when I was a a
freshman at UC Berkeley this was like
2017 right after the Miley Annapolis
protest it happened around Free Speech
afterwards we were sitting in this
classroom right and in this classroom
this professor starts talking about the
protests this one student gets up and
starts shouting at this professor
there's like 15 students in this
classroom I mean this was basically my
introduction of politics in that show
this one student stands up Sarah
chatting with Professor saying there's a
bad idea going a little crazy this other
kid gets up start shouting at the
student so now the students are shouting
at each other right there's two of them
the rest of us 13 are just sitting there
completely silent you know me being my
very you know uh uh normal you know
Asian self-seating authority to those in
power just just sitting back watching
these two go at it 13 of us are saying
I'm like this is insane nobody says
anything we leave the classroom there
are two of us get together we have a
conversation I was like did you like
that nobody like that every everybody
was not nobody was on the same page
everybody felt like this was a terrible
and then I suddenly realized if one of
us had given the other 12 of us the
social permission to stand up and say no
your your method of operating is wrong
it empowers the majority what I see a
hopeful majority of people to actually
do something about it that's just to me
that seems like our politics of the
nutshell there's one person once said
one person the other it's a tyranny of
the minority in in essence yeah uh it's
what we have to do is give each other
permission and then build a tribe
um whether it's Bridge USA or Ford party
and then say look uh guys
um put the pitchforks uh and Molotov
cocktails down please uh and let's try
to figure out how we can live together
and maybe even Advance common Solutions
and I refer to a couple of issues
earlier that you know our divine finding
the American people though there is
actually a pretty strong consensus on on
both of them I mean when I I ran for
president I believe certain things I
think most people can figure out where I
am on on a lot of issues I mean heck I
had like 140 policy positions uh during
the presidential but the main impetus
for my running was that I think this
economy is going to become
dehumanizing and punitive and it already
is and then AI is going to come online
and kick everyone to the curb I was just
on the picket line with the actors and
writers in Hollywood and you know I mean
the studios are trying to
scan a thousand background actors and
then never hire a background actor again
which by the way makes perfect sense for
them it's like you know what what's that
I I need a young handsome South Asian
I've got one right here you know I
should tell my mom back
and then you the individual who got
scanned got paid the one time but they
don't have to pay anyone else ever again
right um and and so the actor is like
well that's not cool at all uh you know
they're 160 000 people in that Union
most of whom are you know just showing
up on set every once in a while and um
having uh like a side income that so
that that's something that we can see
very clearly but there's a bunch of
other stuff uh coming down the pike
that's gonna steal up and take people by
surprise I didn't see chat GPT
developing this quickly when I was
running for president even a few years
ago and folks like Tristan Harris who
keep up with this say they literally
have to update their data every day on
what the heck AI is doing it's not like
you could turn away for two months and
come back and it's the same it's
literally like oh changed again so uh
you know who's not changing again just
like that us you know
yeah
maybe the next day pretty much the same
you know and maybe a little uh I mean
not only are we not changing enough but
we have yet to figure out how to deal
with social media let alone AI I mean
it's like it feels like it feels like
we're we're studying for for a test in
the eighth grade and the 10th grade AP
test is about to come up around the
corner and we've yet to even open that
book and and it seems like nobody
actually the incentive to solve the
challenge it almost in some ways and
this might feel a little conspiratorial
but those of us that are outside of the
political scene and only looking in
sometimes feel like those in power are
actually okay with things being bad
because it makes politics much easier
like I feel like if I was the DNS here
the RNC this is exactly the situation I
would want it's just it's red versus
blue it's easy yeah you that that's one
of the perverse aspects of today Manu
where where
um if things deteriorated actually uh is
probably fine for you in the sense that
it's like oh I can get you more animated
uh and upset I mean right now
um there are small dollar donations are
down cycle over cycle by 25 or so right
uh and they're just like oh what are we
gonna do and you I mean the truth is
that we're all burnt out you know we've
all gotten the freaked out emails over
and over again at this point we're like
oh my gosh by like the 300th freaked out
email like I'm not gonna hit the Donate
Button as fast and then like oh no what
are we gonna do
it's like
um by the way in this case too it you
know may not be the worst thing in the
world because it's affecting both sides
so you know it's pretty much canceled
each other out and that uh you know like
Americans might might be looking for
another uh path forward but yeah the
powers that be don't hate this stuff uh
and the unfortunate truth is that good
policy is probably negatively related to
your job security where if a bunch of
people came forward and said hey here
are a bunch of AI regs there are
probably some big time tech companies
that are like oh I didn't like that uh
and meanwhile if they just grandstand
and like say things then everyone is
fine uh to you know like the problem
Fester because the real players uh are
like okay good they're they're being
cool like that you know and we can
handle them saying things about us we
just don't want them to genuinely
regulate us
so amidst all of this where you know
people's paychecks are online people's
job Securities online There's real
policy issues you know people let's say
uh on the side of thinking that climate
change is real threat see the fires in
Hawaii and they want to get out there
somebody that's a conservative sees the
woke culture War issues being rammed
down their throat and they're like this
is insane we gotta fight this what is
the fundamental argument from your
standpoint and I have a take on this but
I'm curious about yours because you've
pressure tested in front of so many
people what is your fundamental take
on how you break through that noise to
actually make people think about the
system as opposed to
that really unfortunate you know
disaster event in that certain state or
that really unfortunate job loss that's
about to come around the corner and you
say hey we need to vote for the person
that's voting to ensure that primaries
and gerrymandering are not a thing you
know in the way that they are on the
status quo yeah I I try and explain to
them look right now the incentives are
working against us the incentives are
working against good policy and if we
don't change incentives we're just going
to keep uh grinding ourselves uh into
Oblivion so let's try and fix the
incentives and the way to fix the
incentives are getting rid of primaries
and moving towards all party ranked
Choice voting like they did in Alaska
like they just voted in Nevada and it's
going to be on the ballot again in
Nevada uh that there's a race going on
right now around modernizing the system
and the system crumbling before our eyes
now which do I think is going to win I
mean I'm fighting like mad for the first
one and there are things that people can
do one of the exciting things Manu and
one of the reasons why I'm so pumped to
talk to you is I say to people all the
times like what what percentage of
Americans would you get need to get into
something like forward uh and energized
for us to change everything safe
five percent ten percent that's exactly
right you know you don't need 51 you get
five percent of Americans really zeroed
in on the fights like okay we're being
set up yep um you know you need a
foothold in the population yeah yeah
totally I mean you know you have a 20
approval rating of U.S Congress and then
a 94 re-elect rate uh of incumbents like
look we're being set up we're getting
carved into blue and red zones and
they're just pounding Us in the head and
saying there's absolutely nothing you
can do so if five percent of us stand up
and say okay I get the game now and I'm
going to shake it up so you have to
listen to the general population instead
of just your cronies and special
interests and the ideological Edge uh
that's where we're going and we will
vote for people that represent that you
get five percent of Americans into it we
change everything
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
if you're a regular listener you know
that I am a mattress guy and that I
believe investing in your mattress is
one of the smartest savviest things you
can do to be happier healthier more
energized more able to live your life
it's why I'm so pumped to recommend
Helix sleep because they are the
mattress company that will send a
customized mattress to you based upon
your sleep preferences risk-free made in
the USA number one mattress picked by GQ
and Wired Magazine and there is a
special sale for Labor Day the best
discount I have ever seen them offer 25
off that's right Helix is offering 25
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners in honor of
Labor Day probably because a lot of you
are moving need a mattress go to
helixsleep.com Yang and use code Helix
partner 25. this is their best offer yet
and it won't last long with Helix better
sleep starts now
uh certainly want to make common calls
with you and Bridge USA at every turn uh
and really pumped to be able to share
this journey with you uh and uh love the
fact that
um you've gone so far from that College
event till now where most people would
have at some point said you know what
it's med school time or it's j-o-b time
or whatever the heck and not that you
don't have a job you have a very big job
you have the kind of job where if you
and I do our jobs then we might be able
to unlock the solutions to the truly
important problems of this time uh and
without us getting this stuff under
control uh the biggest problems will get
worse
I mean as as your as your friend Dave
Chappelle says it takes one to no one
and what's what's super powerful about
this work right now is I mean I would
not be here without my best friends you
know uh Ross who you met um two or three
weeks ago look at my other room you know
we we have a family behind this and I
think as you know and and this is forget
politics for a second I mean
to build anything of course there's
purpose required there's ambition
required but ultimately it's the people
right and
um I think I I don't know if you get
asked this question a lot when you're on
campuses but oftentimes when I'm on
campuses people ask me all the time
especially younger people like what's
the secret to building something how do
you respond to apathy how do you respond
to burnout and the fact is most
successful people are burnt out
oftentimes there is a lot of apathy like
I learned this from you it's like
actually like the people that you see on
TV
sorry continue on it
yes yes for the record I learned that
successful people are apathetic no I'm
kidding
um no but it's it's the truth is all of
us struggle all of us struggle the
question is what do you do about it you
know
um and and you can either like in some
ways I think the biggest threat to
democracy is not even like blatant
authoritarianism from wherever side you
think it's coming from but literal just
apathy just disengagement oh someone
asked me a number of months ago what do
you think is going to happen and I
answered without thinking at all I said
we're going to slump our way into
authoritarianism
yeah that's that's the trajectory yeah
yep it's it's because you're seeding the
battle space you're seating the battle
space to those voices okay I gotta ask
you a vexing question because it's
coming to my mind right now I can hear
somebody that's listening to this say
you know ask this question I gotta ask
you this question which is how do you
respond to the claim that when you build
that five percent of the population
right when you engage that five percent
within something like the forward party
that it facilitates the it accidentally
backfires and causes you know the rise
of President Trump or it accidentally
backfires and causes the rise of the
Democratic candidate to win
um how how do you think about that well
if we activate the five percent in the
way that we envision
um you could wind up with one two or
three U.S senators who are stand there
and say you know what guys like like
let's do what most Americans want
Congress is harder you might need 10 to
12 members and in this system that's
very very hard
um but one two or three U.S senators is
doable hundreds of Mayors are around the
country is very doable thousands of
locally elected officials including
State reps is very doable and keep an
eye on the forward party for
announcements on that front so the the
forward party we're shooting for 500
aligned elected officials by next year
and that's significant
um and what does it mean for them to be
aligned
um so in some cases it's like look I'm a
Ford party member and that's what I am
I'm a fordist
um so that that's uh you know let's call
them mayor Jordan Marlo in Newberry
Florida that's his Jam he's like I'm a
Ford party member that that's my party
affiliation and then there are others
who are Democrats or Republicans or
nonpartisan who say I'm I'm affiliated
with the forward party which means I'm
down with nonpartisan primaries and
ranchers voting and just trying to get
stuff done and I I want freedom from the
ideological conflict and back and forth
so you get 500 elected officials you
reflect that then that's a genuine
independent political movement and we're
probably going to get there in the next
10 12 months which means it would have
taken two years so I'm super proud of
that and I think we can go Nationwide
like we can impact National Politics as
soon as 2024 we're going to try and
rally independent swing voters in the
swing States so that's Nevada Arizona
Wisconsin Pennsylvania uh Georgia
Michigan
uh North Carolina uh and say look guys
let's go for whichever major party
actually wants to reform the system and
that's something we can do that can
hopefully move us in a positive
direction next year
so people who look at this and say oh
you're going to screw it up somehow be
like well like by on the facts in all of
these 500 000 elected races around the
country 75 percent of them are
uncontested or uncompetitive so there's
not much screwing up going on
um the only thing people are concerned
about at that level is the presidential
and we're not participating in the
presidential so if you want to be
concerned about the spoiler there are
other folks you can go talk to not us if
you want to have the mayor of Fort
Collins be someone who just answers to
you by the way she joined the Ford party
so you know that's specific like
wear your jam if you want sensible
squirrel school board members or County
Executives like that that's us if you
want people who are trying to free
people from like this uh you know lose
lose pass the Baton back and forth while
the house burns uh you know that's us uh
and and one of the things I mean I I
said this in the San Francisco event you
joke about this but like people
um you know because of like press uh
confusion and um frankly like just false
uh assertions like oh you're gonna you
know help Trump win and I'm just like
look you guys are doing that
like you mean you set up a system where
I like I'm gonna be here trying to keep
Trump from winning like absolutely
nothing to do with it like you guys are
serving the you guys are slumping us
toward authoritarianism and folks like
me and man who are trying to energize
people to think for themselves and free
us from A system that is going to end up
in a very dark place probably in the not
so distant future unless something
changes and and I think it's not only
that just you that something changes
because I think to an extent that
changes not only necessary but it's it
shakes up the system but the number one
sentiment again that I hear on the road
is people just saying well All Is Lost
but the fact is that I mean the United
States in 2026 Andrew is going to be 250
years old but that's not actually old in
the state of human history I mean 250
years is a snapshot and while it might
be the oldest democracy I mean when you
think about Empires you think about
nation states I think people need to
recognize that it is within their power
to actually do something about it I
think we have to and this is something
that I think when we think about this
being a foundational founding moment
1776 moment you think about 1939 moment
you think about uh a 2001 moment I mean
we need to deliver a vision where people
actually feel like they have a sense of
purpose and optimism making a difference
because right now people think that you
do something nothing makes a difference
yeah no they they have caught on really
um you know it's like when young people
say my vote doesn't matter guess what
you're probably right I like you it's
probably the case your vote does not
matter uh you know I could tell by based
on where you live
whether it matters or not
um so what type of action should they
take so so and so really it's like so
let's make it matter let's make it
matter not by playing their game but by
saying let's change the game uh let's
build a positive political movement that
you can be a major part of and help
guide real policy conversations at the
local level and eventually the national
level uh that isn't beholden to special
interests uh that wants things like I
mean I'll say what I want like term
limits that would enable young people
like you to actually have power
um you know as opposed to just watching
other people the country up
well you see Diane Feinstein's 90 and
yeah I mean it's painful you know and
there was a time when she was an awesome
vibrant public servant but you know like
at some point you should say hey it's
time for the Next Generation to lead uh
one of the things I I can say
is that if I'm still trying to like uh
cling to the stage uh past a certain age
someone just could grab a hook
and like yank me off I need to play this
clip be like Yang you said you get the
off if you were you know
daughtering I'd be like oh yeah you're
right I am daughtering get me the
off so uh
uh sustainability plan for the Yang gang
um uh that'll be an AI me just doing his
thing
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you
so what we but you're totally right that
there's a lot of like yeah it doesn't
matter like my vote doesn't matter and
the darkest thing this occurred to me
just now it's like I don't matter
um yeah and and which is I think by the
way the deeper problem yeah that is the
deeper problem but to say look
you matter a whole heck of a lot I love
you your country should love you like
that and what we need is a genuine
popular positive political movement to
throw the Yoke off of us and say why are
we letting our country go to hell in a
handbasket when we can do something
about it let's let's elect elect people
and actual answer to us and by the way
what I'm suggesting is like that's not
going to happen in the current system
there is by the way a Princeton study
there is no relationship between what
Americans want and the policy we get no
relationship that was actually a study
um so right now our will is getting
completely distorted and diluted through
this funhouse mirror system uh this
two-party system the primary system the
blue red system the 90 uncompetitive
District system and we need to shake
that up to have a real say to have a
real chance is it easy no is it fast no
is it the only way out yes and Mommy
when you talk about
me and my journey in many ways when I
came off the presidential Trail I had to
reckon with the fact like look like a
lot of people got behind me and
supported me and believed me and I
really appreciate it I loved him loved
them for it I mean it helped make what
could have been like uh devastatingly
bad journey into a positive Journey so
I'm like really really grateful
um and I owed them an answer I owed them
a path and I said look according to my
best analysis uh the best expert like
you know I could find this is the path
and then now I'm here building the path
and super grateful for anyone who wants
to help yeah yeah and I mean I couldn't
I couldn't say this more about you which
is that for anybody regardless of the
politics regardless of how you approach
the work I mean the fact is that in the
most ambitious experiment in the history
of democracy you need incredibly
ambitious people and who cares about
people that are just pushing the current
system when you have to think about
invention I mean Thomas Jefferson Andrew
I just
um this is part of our like board
reading and and I was reading this is he
talked about a revolution every 20 years
now I'm not saying that that's what
we're what we need but the The
Innovation is the engine of democracy
like push people forward yeah I mean hey
it's not every 20 years I mean at least
every 200 years we should probably do
something different
a little bit different 250. and by the
way in Thomas Jefferson's time too you
know what they were not talking about
Democrats and Republicans totally made
up afterwards I mean during the founding
fathers there were like parties bad
George Washington famously on the way
out party's Bad John Adams two parties
would be a great evil across the land
party's bad Thomas Jefferson I mean
Thomas Jefferson kind of Dilly dogged
with the parties a little more but yeah
he was a little bit um but but then this
two-party system got completely
fabricated and installed at the state
level it's not a word about the
Constitution not a word about it really
the federal law was just everyone kind
of put it in place as a giant control
mechanism and then they had two uh
parties just like trading you you get it
I get it you get it I get it until
eventually ended up migrating into this
polarized mess we we have where now
tensions are rising and rising and it's
like a pressure cooker and there's no
release valve
um the only release valve we have in the
system by the way where none of our
votes matter
um is the presidential and that's how
you end up with a like Donald
Trump winning you know it's like um a
bunch of Americans be like yeah it
it's like the only thing I'm given in
this system is a big middle finger so I
guess that's what I'm gonna do and uh
you know and then we didn't even learn
our lesson anyway don't get me started
because you know how we ended up losing
to Trump but a number of things but part
of it was that the DNC freaking shoehorn
Hillary Clinton said this is our
candidate gonna take this thing uh you
know I think Bernie beats Trump and then
uh we're gonna do it again we're gonna
do it again well that's that's a that's
a big can of worms you just have to open
at the end of the podcast but I have to
ask you did why
you and I talk to a lot of people that
voted for Joe Biden and a lot of people
that voted for Donald Trump and it seems
like at this moment there are legitimate
grievances that that people that voted
for Trump have and there seemed to be
legitimate grievances that people have
voted for Biden have how do you deal
with this like moment of of not trying
to create false equivalent how do you
tackle that question of false
equivalencies of the moral I've got the
real answer Manu the only thing that
would work in American life is um we
give whoever loses this election a
replica of the White House and a
four-year contract to go to that replica
and act like the president and just
freaking beam it out to their people and
then everyone will be happy
did have you let Mark Zuckerberg know
that could be an AR world that he could
build there's a totally just like that
that's really the answer just like give
them both what they want and then
everyone's like yeah then their their
perception of the economy will be better
their perception of uh you know what's
going on around them we better be like
yeah it's all about perceptions that's
really where we are in American life
it's all about perception here here I
got I got one last question on my side
and I actually asked you this a while
ago and I'm curious to see if your
answers changed on this which is that
um I often find myself having built and
done this work with like some of my best
friends that sometimes like it really
does suck right sometimes like you just
do not have any energy to go you you're
just exhausted you also feel like what's
the point there's feelings of
existentialism all of that sort of stuff
right and what is your why like what
what what keeps you what's your why like
what why do you do what you do I gotta
say mono I have the most privileged
version of this thing because like I was
a do-gooder you're a do-gooder I love
you for it you and I know do-gooders I
have the best version of this
journey that anyone can imagine because
like I go out on the street and someone
will just say to me it'd be like hey
Yang thumbs up like you know like I get
that every single day more than
that I get people coming to me and being
like oh thank you like you got me
interested in politics thank you you
made more sense than anyone thank you
stick with it I get that every single
day
oh I get that every single day I go out
in public looking like myself I should
say I don't get that every single day
but but if I go to the store or the
airport a particular given day I will
get that uh and that's amazing
you know L.A
um people are telling me they want me to
keep doing stuff and I'll keep doing it
as long as people want me to
um if there comes a day when everyone's
like okay Yang like you know go home
you're 80 whatever I'll be like all
right cool and the way I'm built I'll
actually frankly enjoy going home
because
like that that's
you know I mean that's what you and I
talked about is is we're not driven by
power we're driven by desire to actually
do good and once the time is up the
time's up
oh yeah I would love to work myself out
of a job please America please help work
me and Manu out of our current jobs
um on that note Manu how can someone uh
support you and your work at Bridge USA
bridgeusa.org
100 I appreciate that you know if you're
if you're the parent of a college age
student or a high school age student
bridgeusa.org we got you covered we're
building the largest and fast screen
movement of young people that are ready
to change how our politics look for the
21st century I mean it's ready if you're
a college student you're a high school
student you feel like the college
Democrats the college Republicans don't
matter if you're a stem student if
you're a business person the fact is
that every facet of our life Andrew I
mean you and I talked about this all the
time is experiencing a deep dysfunction
breakdown in our ability to communicate
and that's what bridge is doing we're
building these chapters we're empowering
these folks and alongside leaders and
organizations like yourselves and
leaders that are adjacent to us I mean
you and I talk about we have real
Democrats we have real Republicans we
have real ideologically driven people in
this work because this is not a fight
between left right this is a fight
between temperaments a fight between
mindset it's a fight between whether we
really love it it's the way Tim Urban
would put it it's high and low trying to
elevate things I agree it's it's between
the high brain and the in the low brain
absolutely yeah let's let's Elevate
people's uh brain functioning are you
all a non-profit we're non-profit we're
501c3 oh my gosh it's the kind of
organization that everyone loves to give
to because it is oh my God tax break you
can tell your employer to match it it's
bridgeusa.org people how wholesome is
this look at Manu help keep his parents
happy and off his back
bridgeusa.org I will see you on the
trail my friend Ed at the campus let's
get me to a campus ASAP oh we'll get you
to a campus we already got some requests
in so we're going to get you to campus
and appreciate you gracing our guests in
the hopeful majority yes stay hopeful
majority